Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
No question.
No,
it does seem
like I'm a cybernetic organism.
Living tissue over
this episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim.
Yeah.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my God,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty,
but more important it will help you not screw up when you're doing your
nutritional plannings.
For me.
It just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim.
Yeah,
the boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I've rerecorded the center like 17 times because I saw my brother last night
after a long hiatus apart and we drank I e Tim drank way,
way,
way too much wine.
So I've had some caffeine,
I've had some coconut oil in poo,
air t and this one is going to make it happen.
Folks.
Magic.
Okay.
Honored.
This episode of the Tim Ferriss show is like many others.
It is my job to deconstruct world class performers,
whether they are chess prodigies,
hedge fund managers,
athletes,
actors like Arnold Schwarzenegger or anybody and everyone in between.
And what I mean by that is teasing out the,
the routines,
the morning rituals,
the favorite books,
the behaviors and habits that you can borrow to improve your own life and in a
professional sense and a personal sense.
This episode we have Phil Libin.
Phil Libin is a friend.
He is also the co founder and executive chairman of Evernote.
I use Evernote as you guys probably know every day,
I mean dozens of times a day.
I used it to handle all of the brain dumps and organization of information and
capture of information from my last few books.
I also use it to create a paperless life or as close to it as possible.
And I was introduced to Evernote by you guys on Twitter actually and I want to
say 2008 maybe 2009 when I was revising the four hour workweek and I ended up
recommending Evernote in that once I got hooked on the product then I got to
know Phil and then I became an advisor to the company,
which is super,
super cool.
So I've been an advisor since I want to say 2008 2009 and Evernote now has 150
or so million users and it is your external brain so you can use it to capture
things online so you can read them offline,
you can use it to capture voice notes,
photographs,
scanned documents with your iPhone for instance.
So that you can take a picture of a,
of a receipt of a menu of a contract and then have it [inaudible] so that you
can search the text that just took a photo of later.
Anyway,
I could go on and on about it because I love the product.
I can't,
it's like Uber for me.
I can't live without it.
But in this episode we cover so much more than just Evernote.
But we do dig in obviously to the lessons learned.
And speaking of lessons learned,
Phil shares his favorite lessons learned directly from Jeff Bezos of Amazon,
Reid Hoffman of Linkedin and Hiroshi Mikitani of Rakuten.
And if you don't know who he is,
then you should look them up.
We talk about philosophical and performance systems like stoicism,
electrical brain stimulation,
which I know you guys are into.
And if you want a ton on that,
you can also listen to my Adam Gazzaley episode.
But Phil is experimenting with a brain stimulation,
uh,
for performance enhancement and just general wellbeing.
And we'll talk about that.
Creating tech for yourself and the Evernote genesis story.
They're very closely tied together.
We have some frivolities like the best host in Singapore,
the best hamburger and Tokyo and why goat simulator is amazing.
And then we talk about a longterm thinking,
longterm meaning 10,000 year thinking and real versus imagined threats.
We talk about artificial intelligence and a bunch of others.
Now,
most importantly in general across this episode,
he digs into his aha moments and what he learned in some cases,
how they happened and how you can make that happen for yourself.
So Phil is an awesome guy,
hilarious and just an amazing,
amazing executive.
Now when we recorded this,
he was also CEO of Evernote,
but he has been looking for his successor for some time now.
And uh,
in the meantime,
what between recording this and publishing it,
he found that CEO.
So you can just Google new Evernote CEO and you can get all the goods on that.
In any case,
uh,
you can find the show notes,
all the links,
the book links,
et Cetera,
at four hour workweek.com and just click podcasts.
So four hour work week.com click podcast.
And without further ado,
please enjoy Phil Libin and say hi to him on Twitter at [inaudible] live in Lib.
I N
Phil,
welcome to the show.
Eight.
Tim,
good to be here.
It's a,
it has been a while since we hung out and I've noticed the most conspicuous
change is that the trademark beard has vanished.
And I wanted to know how you decided to make that change because for as long as
I've known you,
I have sort of visualized in my head this beard that you have,
which is,
I guess it's not really a goatee.
It's not really a full years to chin beard.
It's more like a mouth frame.
I Dunno if there's a word for those mouth frame.
Yeah.
That I thought of it as a mouth frame would have shaved so much earlier.
You know,
that's,
that's probably due to my lack of caffeine.
But how did you decide to,
or why did you decide to shave it off?
Well,
I had it literally for 20 years.
Um,
I hadn't shaved in 20 years.
I had this,
had this beard and when I grew at 20 years ago,
I was,
um,
I was trying to look older and you know,
20 years later I figured it was time to start trying to look younger.
That works.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
And for,
for those people who are familiar with Evernote,
one of the questions that I've heard come up quite a bit is,
and we'll get to what Evernote is of course,
but why green for the logo?
The elephants,
people eventually figure out,
but why green?
Well,
so logos is gray.
It's been so it's an elephant,
right?
Because elephants,
elephants never forget,
elephants have great memories and the elephant is gray.
And people ask,
well,
why is he often gray and as well because that's the color elephants are.
And uh,
it's not a green background because that's the color that elephants are usually
on with our,
on grass.
So it's not super elaborate.
Got It.
Natural Habitat Natural.
It is.
Uh,
it is the iconic animal in its natural habitat.
And how,
speaking of of natural habitat,
I'm not going to say iconic animal,
uh,
for either of us,
but when did we first meet?
I want to say it was in a coffee shop,
but do you recall?
Yeah,
it was a,
it wasn't a coffee shop.
It was like a Filipino,
like a Chinese tapioca pearls slash college off Tapioca.
I remember,
I definitely remember those tapioca involved,
uh,
like
in the outskirts of San Francisco.
Uh,
and it was like,
man,
I want to say like 1854 or something.
It was a while ago.
Right.
I think you're using the right,
the Egyptian calendar is probably 2000,
I want to say 2007,
2008 it was early.
Yeah.
I mean I think we had,
we had only recently launched and um,
uh,
and I think,
I think I remember like you tweeted something to your followers about what you
should,
what app you should be using to maybe,
maybe it's to write your next book.
And then I think a bunch of people tweeted back Evernote and then,
uh,
people in my office,
I can got super excited.
And then I think either you reached out to me or I reached out to you.
And then we got together for Tapioca.
So what,
what I remember is that I asked a number of questions.
I was,
I think I was updating the four hour work week and I was looking to replace some
of the tools.
And so I would ask my followers on Twitter,
what is the best tool for x?
What is the best tool for why?
What is the best tool for z?
And Evernote kept on coming up and I was like,
that's impossible.
What is the Swiss army knife of software?
And I looked at it and I was like,
you know,
I really need an intro to this.
I'm having trouble figuring out where to start,
which I think is a common,
a common stumbling block or hurdle for people to get over it.
And then we met up and I remember you took a photograph of the menu,
which was on the wall and shortly thereafter we're able to search all of the
text.
And I was like,
okay,
I get it.
And then I think I started with d paper filing a,
or trying to remove the clutter of paper from my house at that time.
So it was all the business cards,
all of the legal paperwork,
accounting paperwork.
I just scanned it because I knew I didn't have to really organize it per se,
if I could search by the texts that was scanned.
And for people who don't know,
I mean this is,
this was my first use case,
but how would you describe Evernote if you could just maybe give a brief
synopsis of Evernote for folks.
And now of course,
I mean I use it 10 to 20 plus times a day,
but for those people who are not familiar with Evernote,
what is Evernote?
And,
uh,
how did,
how did you become involved or what is your involvement with Evernote?
Well,
would,
we started out as a,
as wanting to build your,
your second brain.
Uh,
we wanted to make something that would just make people smarter.
let you remember everything that you find,
all types of information,
uh,
take notes,
clip things from the web,
put in documents.
Um,
and it,
um,
it would just kind of refined it from there.
So we started out as this very general simple note taking tool.
Uh,
and we've evolved to be a,
what we think are the kind of the essential everyday pillars of,
of productivity.
Uh,
we ever known as,
you know,
is the workspace where you get all your stuff done.
And what are the,
what are the origins of Evernote?
The genesis story?
There's actually two teams that we're working on,
on,
on similar concepts.
So there's a team of people that,
uh,
were headed up by this guy named us stop on Pacheco who is this,
um,
sort of eccentric genius,
inventor,
entrepreneur,
uh,
Russian American guy.
And he had a team of people that uh,
go all the way back to the Apple Newton days.
I don't know if you remember that.
Uh,
this was actually the company that apple pulled out of Russia,
uh,
to do all the handwriting recognition and other cool stuff on the Newton,
like back in the late eighties.
Um,
you know,
way ahead of their time and they've,
they sort of stayed together.
They sold that company.
And then they started another company and sold that company.
And then they weren't,
they'd stayed together as this group working on,
um,
this idea of photographic memory,
basically letting people remember,
uh,
everything,
capture all information in California.
I was in Boston at the time and,
uh,
we had,
I was just finishing up with my second startup,
uh,
and my core team started thinking about,
well,
what do we want to do next?
You know,
we need to start on at the company.
We don't want to have to go get jobs or anything.
Uh,
we're going to do.
And we thought,
well,
um,
strategic unemployment.
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
And,
and our whole insight was let's do something for us.
You know,
cause our first two companies,
we made a for other,
for other people,
you know,
our first company,
we did a ecommerce software for big stores.
And our second company,
we did a security software for governments and banks.
And that was all fine.
You know,
we were lucky enough to be able to sell both companies,
but like,
we're not,
we're not a big retailer,
we're not a government.
So like we didn't really,
we have to wake up every morning thinking,
you know,
what does the customer want?
What does the customer want,
what does the market want?
And we've got tired of that.
We kind of said,
well,
screw with the market wants.
Like,
how about,
what do we want?
Let's just build that.
So we sat around thinking like,
what do we really want?
What do we love?
And we batted some ideas around and,
uh,
our first idea as we said,
well,
you know,
we love video games.
Like maybe we shouldn't make a video game studio.
And we thought,
well,
you know,
if there's already so many great video games,
if you don't have time to play it,
like there's already a giant stack of my desk.
Uh,
so,
you know,
we don't really,
the world doesn't really going to be that much better if we add more video games
to it.
So let's,
let's think of something else.
And this was 2007.
So we thought about,
well,
all this new social stuff is actually kind of cool.
Like,
we like that a lot.
Maybe we should build a social network.
And we thought,
uh,
not,
it's crazy cause you know,
you can't compete with my space.
Like my Smith,
uh,
you know,
we're too late to do anything meaningful there.
So we gave up on that and then we said,
well,
what about productivity?
Like all the productivity tools around us just feel old and crappy and out of
date and largely irrelevant.
What if we make the new version of that?
And,
and that we kind of fell in love with.
So we have two different teams working on the same problem and we,
I met Stefan,
um,
early 2007 and we decided to,
to join forces.
So we actually combined the teams and then recreated the,
the,
the company kind of relaunched the company as a new entity in oh seven,
uh,
and launched our first product and the weight.
And what was the first use case,
the first application of Evernote that really kind of made your eyes pop out
that,
uh,
the,
was there any,
do you have any memories of particular Aha moments with either applications that
you guys came up with internally or applications and uses that your fans and
users came up with?
Well,
it's funny,
you know,
we were,
we were getting going kind of right off Twitter was getting going.
And so for a while,
you know,
I just had an alert for Evernote on Twitter and I could read every single time
at anytime anyone mentioned Evernote on Twitter.
I would see it because,
you know,
it was only like this,
that only happened like a few times a day.
It was a few hundred people on Twitter.
Yeah,
exactly.
So that was,
that was easy.
Uh,
it's,
I literally knew every time anyone said anything on either the internet or
Twitter.
Uh,
how about Evernote?
I wouldn't,
I would either get a Google alert or,
or I would get the tweet alert.
Uh,
so I kept for a while,
I actually knew like every single thing that anyone ever said publicly about us.
Uh,
and it was,
and it was still only like a few things a day.
So it was,
it was kind of a humbling thing.
But I remember this one day pretty early on,
um,
where somebody tweeted to two totally different people tweeted,
one of them tweeted,
um,
uh,
that,
they were a priest and they loved using Evernote to gather information to write
their,
um,
their Sunday sermon.
And I remember seeing that and kind of thinking like,
ah,
that wasn't our intended use case at all.
Like,
we didn't set out to make something that's good for the clergy,
but you know,
it kind of makes sense when you think about it.
Like,
yeah,
if I was a priest and I had to come up with something relatively,
uh,
insightful and witty to say every week I'd probably spend time,
you know,
researching and clipping and writing and like actual,
yeah,
ever notice kind of the ideal thing for that.
So I remember thinking like,
that's kind of a cool,
unanticipated use case.
And then later that day,
some totally different person tweeted,
uh,
not,
not to the first person just,
you know,
independently,
um,
that,
uh,
he loved Evernote because it made it easy to keep track of all of his sins,
so that he could,
uh,
efficiently confess every Sunday.
And I remember thinking like,
yes,
like now we're on to something,
like we've got both ends of the spectrum.
We got,
we got the priests,
we got the centers were like,
we were like fully horizontally integrated,
a theologically integrated,
the horizontal integration,
uh,
and uh,
that,
that was when I was first confident that like May,
maybe we were,
maybe we're onto something.
I,
how do you personally use Evernote?
And I think that the reason I keep drilling into this is because I remember my
challenge was figuring out where to start.
And that's the hardest.
I mean,
that's still the,
the hardest thing for us is people don't know how to get started.
So I guess they're two questions,
right?
Like how do you personally use Evernote?
It'd be curious to hear how,
how you most frequently use Evernote.
And then secondly,
how do you solve that problem?
Because this is not unique to just Evernote,
right?
There are many different products.
Let's say sue grew for instance,
which is this
kind of Plato that hardens into a rubber that you can use for repairing things,
has a similar challenge there.
There are many different tools and products that have that face,
this conundrum.
So the first is how do you like multiple tubes of that?
At my desk right now.
Yeah,
it's great stuff.
It's a,
yeah.
And like,
cause I remember reading about it somewhere and immediately being like,
oh,
that's awesome.
I need to get it right away.
And then I got it.
I got all these like packages that showed up at my desk.
I was like,
okay,
now what?
Like glasses aren't actually broken.
So I don't need it to fix my glasses yet.
Right,
right.
My iPhone cases and broken.
So I have to break it to you as the Sioux grew or what else could I do?
Right.
Yeah.
So with,
with Evernote on a,
on a personal level,
how do you use it?
You know,
I live in it.
Um,
I do everything in it.
mostly I,
I use Evernote to run Evernote.
Uh,
like we built it for ourselves and we're still building it for ourselves.
So all of the day to day things that I need for my job aren't Evernote.
I primarily use Evernote for,
for work stuff,
but I primarily only do work stuff.
Like I don't really have a work life balance.
Uh,
so I used to have more,
more hobbies and skills and,
and,
and I would use Evernote for them as well.
Like I,
I,
I was,
I'm a plausibly okay.
Cook.
And so I had a whole bunch of,
you know,
recipes and techniques and Evernote for that.
Uh,
I was,
uh,
I was trying to learn Japanese at one point that I was using Evernote for that,
but more and more like everything that isn't work related has sort of fallen
away.
Um,
and,
but I just use Evernote for everything work related.
So everything I write,
I write an Evernote.
Uh,
all of our meetings are captured in Evernote.
when I want to know what people in,
in,
in the company are working on.
I,
I look at Evernote,
Evernote kind of gives me an update about a hero.
Here's what all my coworkers are doing that are relevant to,
that's relevant to my day.
Uh,
it's kind of become the,
the essential,
you know,
multiple times a day.
Um,
productivity tool for me.
Yeah.
I'm looking,
well,
I'm looking at questions for you in Evernote right now,
which is very meta,
but,
uh,
and,
and so that actually happens a lot.
Okay.
The first time that I did a,
I remember the first time I talked to a reporter,
um,
you know,
I,
we did our very first like media tour.
I went to like New York City to,
uh,
meet with some,
some journalists and reporters,
you know,
back in probably 2008.
And I remember the first meeting I had,
I don't even remember anymore who the reporter was.
Uh,
but,
um,
he was using Evernote to take notes.
Um,
and you know,
and he had been already kind of for a while.
And so that was a,
that was like,
that was actually the first time I saw it kind of in the wild was somebody using
it to write down,
you know,
interview questions with me.
And so there's like,
there's all sorts of moments like that that I remember being just super cool.
The first time I actually really saw it in the wild,
like out in the street.
It was also in,
I think it was that same trip I was in that was in a Starbucks in Manhattan.
And um,
I was waiting in line to get a coffee and there was a guy in front of me in line
who was like,
I don't,
he looked like an important lawyer or something he was wearing,
I was wearing a very nice suit and he was holding his phone.
He had a Bluetooth headset and uh,
he was holding his phone out in front of his face and he had Evernote on his,
on his phone and he was like jabbing his finger into like something in Evernote
and he was yelling at
over the Bluetooth headset,
like proving a point where like jabbing his finger into Evernote.
And uh,
it was the first time I'd actually seen like somebody use Evernote that,
you know,
he didn't know that I didn't have any connection with and I was going to,
like,
I was standing right behind him,
was kind of going to kind of introduce myself,
but he looked really angry,
decided we decided to just stand there meekly behind them.
So what did you,
what did you think like what was the self talk when you saw that?
Did that trigger any,
any particular thought or feeling in you to see it in the wild for the first
time?
I felt like at some point I should like work on a product that just like make
people a bit more mellow.
But
I have built something that enables people to yell at each other.
That doesn't feel great.
Maybe like maybe we should build some kind of a,
you should build something into the next version that chills people out on
mindfulness.
Timeout.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Well there is that,
uh,
somewhat,
related feature in,
I think it's Siri if you shake the phone is if you're trying to sort of rattle
its brains,
it will,
it might be Google maps.
I don't know which it is,
but it's built into the iPhone.
If you shake it,
it will actually like ask you in some,
in some way.
I can't recall offhand.
Like what is wrong.
Yeah.
I think,
I think Google maps may be,
that's like,
it asks you if you want to submit like a,
like a support request or something like that.
Yeah.
And it's Kinda neat.
So,
but,
but men,
so in other one is,
um,
uh,
I met,
um,
I met a group of,
of,
of monks of Buddhist monks,
um,
at,
uh,
there with plum village.
This is a tick not Hahn's sure.
Monastery.
And uh,
I that's right.
I went to,
I went to here to count Han speak a few years ago.
Uh,
and I don't know,
I didn't know anything about about zen at the time at all.
It was just thought it would be interesting to kind of hear,
I'm sorry,
her and she can use it with a sort of his entourage of,
of,
of monks and nuns.
And uh,
it was all very,
very good,
very peaceful.
And then afterwards he,
you know,
as soon as he left,
I was surrounded by,
by the monks and nuns who are all saying how like they just run,
you know,
they run the monastery in Evernote,
uh,
and uh,
you know,
swapping use cases and it was all really neat.
And so that's when I actually thought we should send someone over there to
record some of their belts.
So they had like these really beautiful,
you know,
ancient,
uh,
mindfulness bells and I thought,
okay,
let's record them.
And actually kind of put them into Evernote as some kind of a anti New York
lawyer at a Starbucks yelling at somebody feature,
but never got around to doing that yet
any day.
Now.
That's amazing.
His first book,
uh,
and I'm blanking on the name,
I want to say it was mindfulness is every step or something like that.
Pieces every perhaps,
which was really intended almost like Marcus Aurelius is meditations to be a
notebook for himself and also his close confidence and new attendees or teachers
at Plum village,
which then later became a book.
That was the first meditation book that really had a tangible concrete impact on
me because the storytelling and the narrative was so was so well done.
Um,
let's,
let's return back to the early days of,
of Evernote when it would be good.
Keep talking about Zen and stoicism to,
cause we,
we,
I think we'll talk about both,
but what,
what I'd love to do,
and maybe this is in between,
maybe it's a bridge between the two,
is as a CEO,
what CEOs did you admire or hope to emulate when in the early days of Evernote?
Because you have roughly how many users at the moment are about 150 million.
Yeah.
So that's a big number.
That's a number that a lot of companies would aspire to.
Of course.
Uh,
and what we'll talk about maybe grow separately,
but as a CEO,
you know,
what types of leaders or CEO's did you
Meyer and aspire to?
Well,
you know,
there's so many that have been really generous with their time,
uh,
with me.
I mean,
that's really kind of the amazing thing about silicon valley is just how kind
of,
how open everyone has been.
Um,
so I was able to spend quite a bit of time talking with,
you know,
with people who are just,
we're just heroes of mine forever.
So,
you know,
Jeff Bezos,
um,
as someone who's given me kind of fantastic,
fantastic advice and guidance.
Um,
Hiroshi Mikitani,
the founder and CEO of Braca 10 is one of the most amazing people ever.
I have you,
have you ever talked to him?
I haven't.
I would lie.
You got to,
you should.
He's,
that guy is crazy and like in a really good way.
Like,
very,
very interesting.
I know,
I know you have,
uh,
a big Japan connection,
so I do.
Yeah,
that'd be a blast.
Um,
but,
you know,
but I,
I had a chance to,
to,
to very briefly need,
uh,
Steve Jobs.
Uh,
I had a chance to,
uh,
I've actually spent quite a bit of time with,
with Marc Benioff,
who's been really excellent in terms of advice and guidance.
So it's been like,
it's been pretty impressive.
Um,
probably the person that I kind of most want to be like when I grow up is Reid
Hoffman.
Uh,
just a huge fan of,
of,
of read and kind of the way that he thinks about things and uh,
how,
how thoughtfully he's organized his life and his companies.
I'm just going to very cool.
So I'm lucky to,
uh,
to actually be able to,
you know,
spend some time with these people
from time to time.
I do agree.
I was actually just chatting with someone about the differences between Say New
York and San Francisco,
La and San Francisco,
and their strengths and weaknesses to all of them,
but the,
the,
the ability to wander into a coffee shop or otherwise just get in touch with
what you would think would be the untouchables,
the very,
very well known iconic figures is something that I haven't seen in many other
places outside of Silicon Valley.
Just the,
the openness and availability that those people express,
even though they're ads,
the multibillion dollar in net worth mark,
it's,
uh,
it's very,
it's very unique.
Wa I don't know if you agree with that,
but,
uh,
what,
why do you think these people are so open to share?
What,
what makes the environment of Silicon Valley different or what makes the people
who gravitate to at different,
well,
I don't know that it's,
I don't know that this is unique about silicon valley.
I think we just have a larger concentration.
Maybe if people like this,
but,
but they probably exist everywhere.
I just think,
you know,
almost everyone here who is a,
who's successful,
who's made,
who has made it quote unquote,
it was well known,
like remembers doing it him or herself,
right?
Like before they build this giant world changing multibillion dollar thing,
they haven't done it either.
Uh,
and it,
it isn't like,
it's not,
it's all like,
and sort of the recent past as well,
like virtually everyone who you read,
who,
you know,
who I really admired,
like it has gone from just being a normal person to bending the universe in a
significant way in the last decade or two.
Yeah.
Um,
as opposed to,
you know,
in,
in other places where a lot of,
a lot of wealth is concentrated in people who,
you know,
sort of maybe have inherited part of it or who have kind of been in those
circles for longer.
This is very much a,
you know,
scrappy entrepreneurial,
a lot of,
a lot of immigrant led,
uh,
communities and,
and everyone remembers before,
before they were important,
they weren't.
Uh,
and that's,
that's kind of a healthy thing.
I want to ask you a little bit about the folks that you interacted with.
So may Bayzos for instance,
he's a fascinating character on so many levels.
I mean,
very methodically chose books,
pitched that within de Shaw,
had it turned down,
uh,
and then turned it into the everything store.
And when they started they had a,
as a,
as I understand it,
um,
basically doors from the equivalent of home depot across two file cabinets,
desks.
I mean,
that's how people started out.
What did you we did that.
And my first startup we had,
we made desks out of,
out of,
we made desks out of a unfinished doors and,
and,
and uh,
what do you call those little construction horses?
Oh,
the saw horses.
So the horses,
yeah,
that was our first desks are all,
we just bought doors at home depot and put them on saw horses for no good
reason.
It turns out that's like harder horse.
It was really funny.
I just built this a side note,
pull up rig out of a galvanized steel piping and plumbing supplies and whatnot.
It's just at the end of the day it costs,
particularly if you factor in the labor,
it's like,
okay,
it was a fun project,
but probably would have been better use of capital just to buy a cheap rig it.
But it's still fun in its own way.
One of these days,
Tim,
you have to like,
you have to like coach me to be able to do a pull up.
Like I would like to do a pull up once in my life.
I will absolutely help you do that.
And maybe we can pull in pop by Pavel Tsatsouline who like yourself is
originally from the former Soviet Union.
Uh,
now you were born in,
I want to say Saint Petersburg,
but am I getting that right?
Well,
it was called,
let me write it at the time,
but yeah.
Leningrad.
And uh,
do you spell,
I'm not going to quiz you,
but do you still speak Russian?
I don't speak Russian.
Yes.
And with such a heavy,
I'm not going to lose track of where we were with Bezos,
but with,
with such,
I want to come back to that.
But with such a heavy Russian,
uh,
component in Evernote from the early days,
how did that affect the company culture or growth or anything if it,
if it did?
I don't know if it did.
I don't,
I,
I'm not sure that it had that much.
I don't,
in fact,
you know,
the original team on Stefan side where we're mostly Russians.
Uh,
I,
you know,
most of the people would meet weren't,
there's a couple,
I don't really think of myself as particularly Russian.
I was,
I was eight years old when we came over.
You know,
I learned English by watching,
uh,
what's happened in reruns and reading Thor comic books.
I would have loved to have heard your English and your early days.
Yeah.
It turned out that my colloquial English came from Thor.
Uh,
I wasn't the most popular kid in,
in,
in junior high school.
A lot of praise and talk,
but it was good for vocabulary development sorts of,
you know,
forsooth
hence forth.
Um,
and um,
but you know,
we just,
we had a really great,
we've had a really great team.
I don't think there's anything particularly particularly Russian or not about
the company and certainly in Silicon Valley there are,
I think,
I'm sure this must be true,
that most people who work at Evernote are from somewhere else.
Uh,
Eh,
you know,
I think we probably have more than 50% people born outside of this country.
Um,
there's just such a heavy immigrant community.
and we just,
you know,
you pull people from all over.
We want to get the best people from everywhere in the world to,
uh,
to help us build a great product.
Speaking of that process of building a great product,
uh,
or maybe not what,
what advice did you go to Bayzos for or what were some of the questions you
asked him or pieces of advice that he gave you,
if you remember?
Good.
I got it.
Okay.
The last thing he told me,
this was only just like a few days ago,
but it's changed my life again.
Like basically every time I talked to Bayzos it's like changes my life.
The last one was,
was just recently and it was kind of amazing,
not particularly relevant to the topic at hand,
but,
but super epically awesome.
Anyway,
so I've spent my entire life thinking that,
uh,
I want to go to Mars,
like Mars,
Mars,
Mars.
It was like on the Brady Bunch.
Right?
Okay.
Just want to go to Mars.
Um,
I thought this was like the best thing ever.
At some point,
if I structured my life correctly,
maybe I'll get to go.
Like maybe like later on in life.
I would totally agree to go,
you know,
to go one way.
Cause I think it's just so important for humanity to,
to be able to do that.
I was just all into Mars and,
uh,
you know,
talk to Ilan a couple of times and just vastly inspired by everything that,
that,
that he's doing and what SpaceX is doing.
And,
um,
I was listening to Ilan speak,
uh,
last week or two weeks ago or something talking about Mars and I was super
inspired and um,
you know,
ran into Jeff Bezos a bit later and was kind of saying,
oh I just got to talk to Ilan and I'm super excited about Mars.
I'm really hope that one day I can go and,
and,
and Jesus looks at me and goes,
Mars is stupid.
And like what is that?
Yeah,
once humanity,
once we get off of,
once we get off the planet,
the last thing we want to do is,
is go to another gravity.
Well the whole point like the reason that this is so hard to get off the earth
as dude like defeat gravity the first time.
Once we do that,
why would you want to go to Mars?
We should just live on space stations and mine asteroids and everything is much
better than being on Mars.
And in like 30 seconds,
he had like completely changed the course of my life work cause he's totally
right.
And I was like,
what
mid day conversation?
It was like a late night after a few drinks conversation.
Um,
it was after a few drinks.
I'm not sure what time of day it was.
That's a great answer.
Anyway,
anyway,
so now,
so now I know that the future of humanity is to live on space stations and mine
asteroids and uh,
uh,
hopefully I'll get to do that at some point.
Um,
uh,
other advice that I've gotten from them has been a bit more practical.
All right,
well I'm not going to,
I'll bait.
What other advice?
Well,
I mean the best thing that he's been at in terms of like actually building the
company is just,
you know,
it's just scaling issues.
It's like a,
you know,
how do you deal with things when you're a,
when you were 20 people,
how does that change when you're a 200,
how do you think about going from 200 to 2000 to 20,000?
Um,
it's all the kind of the,
the,
the growing pains,
the life stages of the company.
I mean that,
that's what's really occupies most of my attention professionally.
Now.
Um,
this is also what Hiroshi Mikitani is fantastic at,
like between,
between Mikitani [inaudible] and be Zos.
Those are like,
you just get everything that you possibly want to know about,
uh,
about how to scale a company.
Uh,
and I've,
I've every chance I get to to,
to,
to actually pick their brain at it.
That's usually what we're talking when we're not talking about space stations
and Mars and things like that.
What are some of the biggest challenges that you've had in scaling Evernote?
Well,
uh,
make a tiny son says this really cool thing.
He's got this law,
it's like he's calls it like the law of three and 10 or something,
which is basically that every single thing in your company breaks every time you
like roughly tripled in size.
So,
uh,
basically like,
because he was the first employee at ragtime,
he was there,
he was number one and now they've got an old 10,000 or something or more.
They said when you were like the first person,
when you're just one person,
like everything kind of works,
you've sort of figured it out.
And then at some point you have three people and now things are kind of
different,
like making decisions and everything with three people.
It's like different,
but you adjust to that and then you're fine for awhile and then you get to 10
people and everything kind of breaks.
But then you figure that out and then you get to 30 people and everything's
different and then a hundred and then 300 and then a thousand.
Um,
so his,
like,
his hypothesis is that everything breaks at roughly this like this,
these points of three and 10 are roughly a tripling every size,
uh,
and buy everything.
It means like everything.
Like,
you know,
how you,
uh,
how you handle payroll,
hot,
how you schedule meetings.
Um,
what kind of communications do you use?
How you do budgeting,
you know,
who actually makes decisions like every implicit and explicit part of the
company just changes significantly when it triples.
Um,
and his,
his insight is,
um,
a lot of companies get into huge trouble because of this.
Um,
so when you're quickly growing startup,
you get into huge trouble because you,
you,
you blow right through a few of these triplings without really realizing it.
And,
uh,
and then you turn around and you realize that like,
oh,
like,
you know,
we're at 400 people now at Evernote and when I really think about it,
I'm like,
okay,
we were 400 people now,
but some of our processes and systems are we set in place when we were 30.
So we kind of skipped like a few steps and everything is like creaky and broken
because of it.
Whereas you really have to,
like,
you really have to try to adjust.
Uh,
so startups get in trouble because you,
you kind of blow through these,
these,
uh,
these break points really quickly.
And so you should constantly be thinking about perpetually be thinking about how
to,
how to reinvent yourself,
uh,
and,
and how to tweak the culture.
But then big companies get in trouble for exactly the opposite reason because,
uh,
you know,
let's say you get to,
10,000 people in your company.
Like,
I'm theoretically,
you figured out how to run things at 10,000,
well your next big point isn't until 30,000 but you probably not going to get
the 30,000,
you know,
ever or certainly not within a few years.
Like it may take,
you know,
a decade or more for a company go from 10,000 to 30,000 people,
but no one feels like waiting around for a decade or more to like reinvent
yourself.
And so companies are like constantly pushing all of this like bullshit,
like innovation initiatives because they feel like,
well we have to do something,
we have to do something.
But they're not actually connected to any fundamental change in the company
there.
They're just kind of floating around by themselves.
So by having this mismatch,
like when things actually change and when you feel that you should actually redo
everything,
um,
small companies get in trouble,
the big company is going to trouble.
And just being mindful about that is,
is super eyeopening.
So that,
that was maybe like one of the most actionable pieces of advice that I got.
And this was from,
from Hiroshi Mikitani had written the,
this is very interesting,
the,
the law of three and 10.
Now the,
the tripling I get,
where does the 10 come in?
Oh,
it's because otherwise it'd be three and nine.
It'd be harder to do the math.
It's just,
Oh,
it's just rounding up.
He's basically saying IC three and then 10 and then 30 and then 100.
Otherwise you'd be,
you'd be nine and 27 and so on.
Yeah.
Who can,
who can do that?
Man.
Oh Man.
The,
um,
have you ever,
now I know you,
you like myself.
I have a fondness for Japan.
Have you ever seen someone trained previously trained on an abacus as a kid do
mental mathematics?
Yeah.
It's so fascinating.
I mean,
you could say,
put their,
put their finger up in the air like they're moving beads.
And I remember there was this kid on my judo team when I was in Japan as an
exchange student for a year.
Who could do,
you could multiply three digit numbers.
He could do pretty much whatever basic arithmetic you would ask him to do by
using this sort of imaginary advocates.
So fascinating.
Yeah,
my grandmother was a,
was a,
was that a bookkeeper was an accountant,
uh,
in,
you know,
in the Soviet Union.
And,
um,
you know,
she was all,
it was all Abacos training for her.
And I just remember,
uh,
I remember when I was a kid,
like she would do math and I,
yeah,
I completely remember just being blown away by like kind of how that work yet
with the,
with the imaginary abacus,
with,
uh,
Mikitani sons,
law of three and 10 in pragmatic planning terms,
does that mean that you is Phil at Evernote would try to look ahead to
anticipate when you would hit that tripling point and then seek out the new
tools and processes that you would need beforehand?
We've really tried to,
uh,
and,
but I also think like,
so there's the whole tripling aspect,
which I think is interesting.
Uh,
obviously this is just,
you know,
it's just a framework.
It doesn't really capture every nuance.
But then it made me think about another thing,
which I think is maybe even more important as to like how the world is changing
now.
Like important changes happen,
like App Times of,
of uh,
of change and it sounded like a fatality.
Um,
that's not how I meant to say it.
let me put it this way.
So people will often ask,
people will often say to a about a product like,
oh,
but that's you're,
you're really asking people or companies to like change their ingrained
behavior.
Like how long does it take to change a green behavior?
Like we're saying,
okay,
email socks,
like email's dead.
You have to get off of,
uh,
obviously.
And a lot of people say,
oh,
but that's such ingrained change.
Like how long will it take a company to,
you know,
to,
to fundamentally get off of email.
And,
um,
I've been thinking about it like this.
Um,
every time you change jobs,
it's like a very good opportunity to reevaluate,
sort of what works,
what doesn't work and trying to be a little bit smarter the next time around.
Every time you had like a major life change that could change jobs or you move
into a new house or whatever,
uh,
you know,
you get married and like any,
all of these stuff follow,
all of these things kind of are a really good opportunity.
Sort of take stock mentally and be like,
ah,
okay,
we're going to,
I've always wanted to do this a little bit better,
now's the time I'm going to do that.
And so inside of companies that's basically people changing jobs and you can
measure how long,
like a fundamental corporate,
um,
change will take based on just the number of job cycles that it requires.
So let's just say that like something as profound as like getting rid of email.
It will take like three entire cycles of like people changing their,
their,
their job.
Like,
um,
but,
and this explains like why things happen at such different paces in like in
silicon valley versus in,
on the east coast versus in like Europe,
because the tenure,
the average tenure of professionals of knowledge workers is really shrinking and
as much shorter here than in lots of other places.
You know,
the average tenure of a Google employee right now is something like 1.1 years.
Like the average person has only been in the job for a little over a year.
They're changing jobs all the time.
I mean,
and at apple it's only like two point something years.
And it Evernote,
it's a little bit longer but not much.
And so you constantly having like everyone is basically acting like a,
like a freelancer.
Like everyone is,
is doing a job.
They don't think they're going to do it forever or they think they can do it for
a couple of years and then they're moving on to the next one.
And that's happening.
That's happening like crazy here in silicon valley and it's starting to happen
everywhere.
And so if you,
if like a big change,
let's just say hypothetically,
it takes three job cycles.
Well,
um,
if the average job cycle is like a year and a half,
then okay.
You know,
within four or five years,
the company is like completely change this fundamental thing.
Whereas if you're in Europe and the average job cycles like 10 years,
it may take him 30 years to get there.
So like a change that's obvious here within a few years may take,
you know,
may take decades in societies where that,
where people are just staying on board for much longer and,
but something that takes like something that takes four to five years in Silicon
Valley probably takes 20 years in Europe,
probably takes like a year in China,
that cycle and China's crazy fast and compressed.
Yeah.
Really,
um,
so hot.
Like how do you plan that?
And more importantly,
we at Evernote are building software.
We're building products for modern knowledge workers.
How do we embrace this?
Like how do we build products for these types of people?
Uh,
and that's a very different idea then,
you know,
then Microsoft office,
like how do you build something that is meant for people who are,
have a really compressed job cycle,
who think of themselves as,
as freelancers,
even if they're part of a company.
Uh,
and how do you make that great,
like instead of trying to pass judgement on this and saying that's a bad thing
and trying to hold it back,
how do you actually embrace it and how do you try to make it more awesome?
And that's,
that's a big animating force of power.
We're thinking about things.
How different is the current Chinese version of Evernote compared to,
say the US version?
It's the same.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
there's minor differences and,
you know,
like payment methods and stuff like that.
So we run,
China's the only place where we would run a totally separate version.
So we,
you know,
we have a version of a,
of Evernote,
they'd be called a inch on BG,
which basically we kind of cloned ourselves in China.
Everyone told us like,
oh,
you,
you know,
if you go to China,
you're just gonna get cloned.
So he said,
all right,
let's just clone ourselves.
So we made a full clone of Evernote that we run ourselves,
that's,
you know,
separate data centers,
separate servers.
And,
uh,
other than some minor things around how we interact with payment methods and
stuff like that,
it's exactly the same.
I appreciate it.
The separate data centers that that's important,
that's important for,
you know,
for a bunch of reasons,
for both,
for performance as well as for just sort of giving people the choice as to where
they keep their data.
So yeah,
that,
let's,
let's talk for a second about a Reid Hoffman and then I want to come back to
some of your personal productivity habits.
But Reid Reid is a very interesting,
that's my laziest adjective I can use here.
He's a,
uh,
interesting.
He's a compelling character.
Uh,
I've,
I've had the opportunity to spend a little bit of time with him and we're both
involved in a nonprofit called questbridge and,
uh,
he is,
he is such a cool,
as a cucumber,
sort of philosopher king in the minds of so many people in Silicon Valley.
Uh,
what makes read unique?
What are the things that make him,
that draw you to him or that,
uh,
that,
that you find fascinating about him?
Well,
uh,
you know,
well before I like actually got to know him.
I was,
I was listening to them and I was reading,
you know,
his stuff.
So I mean I was just attracted to the,
to the ideas.
Like he just has a very,
to me it's,
it's the exactly the right balance of kind of big picture,
philosophically oriented ideas that are really grounded and practical and that
you can,
you know,
that,
that you can apply.
Uh,
I really liked the thinking behind linkedin and kind of what it represented.
Um,
so it was the,
it was the,
it was the strength of the ideas and,
and,
and having the exactly,
the right mixture of kind of lofty and,
and practical.
What else?
These,
are there any or any particular examples that jump out at you or any advice that
he's given you or questions that you've asked of him?
Well,
you know,
we talk a lot about,
about,
um,
companies scaling and we talked a lot,
you know,
he made a decision fairly early on that he didn't want to be the CEO of,
of,
uh,
of the company.
And he brought in actually a couple of people,
Jeff as the second person that,
that,
that he wound up bringing on and that worked out great.
And so I've talked to him a lot about,
you know,
what does,
like,
what does that like,
like how do you,
what's the right amount of letting go?
What is the,
what is the,
you know,
the right amount of,
of,
of staying involved.
How do you really think about that?
And he's been kind of my main,
uh,
guide through this.
I mean,
there's been a lot of other people I've talked to as well,
but read is kind of the person that I'm most looking to emulate.
Um,
his thoughts around,
you know,
really starting with paypal.
They have been super influential.
The the best I think,
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
I think the best thing that I've,
that I've read from him is actually more recent.
It was his,
his uh,
Le last book,
the Alliance,
uh,
which really like us sharpen my thinking significantly around this exact idea
that we just talked about,
this idea of having a relationship between companies and employees.
That's more honest.
And that's about recognizing what the actual new realities of the world are and
trying to embrace them.
And he's writing this book really from a kind of an HR perspective.
I really read it as a,
as a product design perspective.
I read it out,
that's interesting.
We make products for this reality and that,
and that's been,
that's been really usually influential.
Plus he's just a super nice guy.
Yeah.
He,
uh,
he is,
he is a very different energy from almost all the other folks in the paypal
Mafia.
Uh,
and that's not to in any way denigrate them,
but he,
he has,
he doesn't seem to have the same sharp edge that a lot of those other guys do.
Obviously he's very intelligent and has an extremely incisive intellect,
but when you sit down with them,
he has a much more relaxed energy,
if that makes sense too.
What would you attribute that?
I mean,
and
he does have,
I would attribute that to like the extreme edginess and sharpness of the rest of
those guys.
I think you,
you put anyone in contrast with,
uh,
you know,
with the rest of the well known people there and like everyone's going to see
him,
anyone's going to see
Tim Ferriss like in a room next to,
you know,
Ilan and Roelof and Max and the people like that are going to seem super mellow
and chill.
All right,
that's a good point.
That's how that works.
Now you,
you mentioned philosophy a bit earlier and you,
and you,
you mentioned stoicism read.
Did I?
Maybe I am.
Okay.
Maybe I just sort of recursively incepted myself.
Uh,
the Reid has quite a philosophy background as I understand it.
I think he,
he studied philosophy at Oxford after his Stanford and experience.
Uh,
are you religious or philosophical?
I mean,
are there any particular schools of philosophy or trains of thought in religion
that you have,
is uses a framework in your life?
Um,
I'm not,
I'm not particularly religious,
uh,
in the fence.
I'm not,
you know,
I'm not the ethic.
Uh,
I,
I am very interested in having a coherent philosophy of life,
like a coherent structure that basically says like,
here is,
you know,
here is why you should bother living in here is what you should try to
accomplish.
And here is,
uh,
here's what it all means.
And I think a lot of people,
a lot of people come,
come to that from a religious backgrounds.
Some people come to it from a philosophical background or practical background,
but I think it's important,
at least for me to just to,
to think about overall structure and to have a coherent philosophy of life.
So I've been,
uh,
I've been looking for that for,
for awhile.
How do you go about looking for it and what have you found?
Any pieces of it?
A little bit?
Um,
uh,
you know,
mostly I just,
I read a lot and I kind of have been,
I was a,
um,
you couldn't tell those by talking to me now,
but I was kind of a strange kid growing up.
Uh,
I,
I sort of became fixated by,
um,
by the end of the world as,
as a,
as a kid.
Uh,
I remember,
um,
I don't know why,
uh,
I remember the first,
like I was really,
really intrigued and kind of obsessed.
There's a little kid with this idea of,
of how the world's going to end.
And,
um,
my,
the first movie I ever saw,
um,
I was six,
it was in Russia and my father took me to see this movie in a movie theater that
was a,
I was just like little,
like super nerdy,
impressionable,
you know,
six year old kid.
And My,
my dad took me to see,
um,
this Japanese horror movie called legend of the dinosaur,
which was about like dinosaurs,
like coming back to life.
It's the most Japanese title ever.
I love the legend of dinosaur.
And uh,
this was just like extremely bad parenting.
Like seriously,
I don't know what he was thinking and uh,
you know,
and I couldn't sleep for like for like a month afterwards.
It was like too terrified to sleep cause I was like,
I thought the world was going to end cause dinosaurs are going to come back and
fight all of us in half.
That's what Beetlejuice did to my brother as a settlement.
Yeah.
Uh,
and uh,
I remember one day,
one day,
like I just one night I was lying in bed,
I couldn't sleep and I think my dad kind of got tired of me not sleeping and so
he came over and I remember he's,
you know,
he sat on my bed and he's like,
Hey,
what,
you know,
what are you afraid of?
What?
Like what,
what are you worried about?
And I said,
well dad,
uh,
to be honest with you,
I'm afraid that the world's going to end because you know,
dinosaurs are going to come back and bite all of us and half.
Um,
and he said,
look,
uh,
like in hindsight I shouldn't have taken you to see that movie.
Um,
you don't have to worry about it.
Dinosaur to definitely not going to come back.
The world is definitely not going to end with dinosaurs coming back and,
and eating us.
You know,
the world's going to end the nuclear war.
Um,
and dead.
It was that,
you know,
that's what everyone thought.
I mean this was like,
this was,
I don't know,
late seventies and in the Soviet Union.
Um,
and that's kind of what everyone thought.
And then we moved to the u s and that's what everyone thought here.
And so I've been kind of thinking about like,
what is the meaning of life and what is like,
what happens when things end and if things are going to end,
like what,
what's the purpose of having a purpose?
Uh,
and I just,
you know,
read a lot of Thor comics and then went on to maybe,
somewhat more serious things and in high school and in college and got into
that.
And I,
I think I'm starting to piece things together.
I think I have a generally sunnier disposition towards life.
And I think I have inklings of,
of what meaning is,
but I'm not sure I understand.
I know completely.
I am.
More recently,
I've been reading a lot of of stoicism stuff.
So you said Marcus Aurelius and a few others.
So I think that's like that's going to be the new trend.
The,
I'm calling it right here.
This is going to be the new trendy thing and silicon valley like zen was sort of
like last year's thing.
The new,
the new zen is going to be stoicism.
Um,
it would have gone like Zen and then macrons and then stoicism.
There was like a diversion macaroons.
What was the second one?
Macrons yeah,
fancy macaroons.
Oh Wow.
Macro runs that's taken the wrong.
Maybe like toast,
like artisanal toasts is also big.
So maybe it goes like Zen and then artismal toast and then stoicism.
But you're going to hear more and more about stoicism and being like the hip new
philosophy coming out of here.
I agree.
I've been trying to do my part with the proselytizing of Stoicism,
which in and of itself is kind of ironic.
But the artisanal test,
if you ever go to,
you know,
cause she'd a park in Tokyo,
they have an artisanal toast coffee shop set up in the park where they have
panda faces burnt into the sides of the toast that you can buy.
It's,
it's fantastic panda faces in artisanal or not,
not to concepts that go together usually,
but what's the weight one?
They can pull it off.
Hold on a second.
What image would it have to be,
if not pandas or is it image lists?
Does it have to have some type of like brand on it or how do you,
how do you envision artisanal toast?
I think it just has to be,
you know,
like perfectly toasted.
I don't,
you know,
it shouldn't be,
it should be a no logo.
It's like the 15 minute pour over of toast.
That's right.
Well,
the best toast best folks in the world is in Singapore.
Uh,
it's Kaia toast.
So you get like,
you get these thick slabs of,
of,
of toast,
um,
spread with a butter and Kaia.
Kaia is like this like sweet coconut spread and then you dip it into really
runny,
soft boiled eggs and you have a pulled coffee.
So this coffee that they pour over like six feet in front of you,
it's the best over 600 feet.
Is it like a game of Thrones poor from across the room?
Like Chinese style?
That's,
yeah.
Yeah.
So you get this like really air rated coffee,
uh,
sweet toast dipped into runny eggs.
Best thing ever.
I'm just imagining this Willy Wonka like chocolate,
a chocolate colored coffee waterfall that you put stick your Mcginn too.
I'm not sure that's the proper image,
but it does give me some ideas.
So the uh,
let's step outside of Evernote for a second.
Um,
what are the most used apps on your phone besides Evernote?
well,
so basically,
so to me Evernote doesn't really feel like an APP.
Like I use,
you know,
I use like,
I think of,
you know,
email messaging web and Evernote.
That's kind of like the same order of things.
Uh,
so like it doesn't,
it doesn't even feel like I'm using an app when I use it.
I'm just,
you know,
I'm just using it.
I use,
you know,
so I use a bunch of the messaging apps,
um,
really kind of to test them out to sort of see,
see how things are going,
see what's,
see what's impressive,
where the good ideas coming from.
But again,
even there they don't really feel like,
like apps.
In fact,
this is probably the thing,
it was like things that I use all the time I don't think of as apps.
Like I don't think of Uber is an APP.
Like I use Uber quite a bit.
Um,
it doesn't really feel like an APP to me.
Is it a utility or what is the wood?
How do you compartmentalize APP?
What does that,
what does that feel like when you do use in that it's like a service I guess.
Um,
so I,
one of my,
one of my product hypotheses is that apps are like apps are going away.
The concept of an APP is going to become a lot less important than a few years.
And it is now.
So like this,
this whole idea that your like page through screens of stuff to pick something
you want to use like that,
that that's a short term concept.
That's only,
it's only going to be,
have been with us for a decade or so and then it will vanish and there'll be
replaced with this concept of just,
you know,
experience of services.
So,
you know,
Amazon,
I mean I use the Amazon App,
we don't think of it as an APP.
I use Netflix,
but if that's not an APP,
uh,
one things that had just become these like permanent fixtures in my life,
their fixtures,
but they're not,
they're not apps and I use them.
I'll use them everywhere.
I'll use them on a phone,
I'll use them on the web,
I'll use them on my watch,
you know,
at some point in my glasses,
whatever.
Um,
in terms of like discreet apps that I use on the phone,
um,
a lot of games.
I,
I mostly just the,
like all of the specific small things on my phone.
She sent to be games that I'm trying out.
What are your favorite games?
Uh,
I go through them pretty fast.
Like right now,
like,
you know,
for the past couple of days I've been playing a radical repelling,
which is,
you know what it sounds like
repelling like rappelling down the side of a rock face.
Yeah.
You like to repel down the side of a rock face and you get power ups and tried
drawing or avoid running into spikes and like drink cans of highly caffeinated
beverages that give you a burst of energy.
It's,
it's very,
it's very much like real life.
Before that I was kind of into goat simulator.
So of goat simulator on iPhone is pretty good.
It's the best.
It's definitely the best goat simulation that you can get on your iPhone.
And do you use these games to decompress?
Have you always been a Gamer?
Yeah,
I have.
Um,
I usually play,
I used to play a lot more like computer games.
Uh,
now I don't have quite as much time.
Um,
although I did recently start playing elite dangerous,
which is dangerous.
Elite,
dangerous.
Yeah.
It's,
it's probably the greatest game,
maybe thing ever made.
Okay.
Uh,
elite and like elite force,
but then dangerous the adjective.
Yes.
I guess that's a space game.
Uh,
just came out and amazing and,
and,
and like,
like Jeff Bezos is basically envisions a world where humans are everywhere in
space but,
but mostly living on space stations,
mining asteroids,
not really going down to planets.
So sort of to two factors for that.
How,
how long,
how far away are we,
do you think from mining asteroids?
Because I know there's,
for instance,
planetary resources,
which Peter Diamandis is involved with.
Brian Johnson is an investor,
couple of other folks,
a lot of the uh,
uh,
sort of zero gravity guys are involved,
um,
with planetary resources,
which is focused specifically on mining precious materials off of asteroids.
We,
when do you think will will actually be,
you know,
I in full swing,
it's really hard to say.
I think the most important thing to nail first is the reusable,
like repeatable,
uh,
launch vehicles.
And that tourism was probably going to get us there before,
before mining does.
Um,
so I'm actually kind of a big fan of a lot of the,
a lot of the space tourism efforts like virgin galactic and a few others just
because I think not because I think it's particularly great to send people into
Lord,
but I mean that's fine.
But I think like we need to,
we need to get the reusable rockets and launch vehicles going as much as
possible and that'll really unlock everything else.
And I think so I think we will have pretty good repeatable,
reusable launch vehicles within,
you know,
five years.
But then how long does it go from there to asteroid mining?
Uh,
I dunno,
that could be decades.
Um,
especially since it doesn't really make sense to mine asteroids and then ship
the results back to Earth.
Like it probably makes sense to actually just move industry into space.
So you should be mining asteroids and building things in space stations.
And the only things that should be coming back to earth is basically,
you know,
data like we should be getting,
fast internet connectivity from space.
And that's about it.
Like everything else should be just be being made,
you know,
up there.
So that's,
but that's,
you know,
a above my pay grade B,
I have no idea what I'm talking about and see probably a few decades away.
So,
uh,
let's,
let's continue talking about things,
at least above my pay grade.
Uh,
but,
uh,
still might be within yours.
I think the,
if you were looking at the end of the world,
the things that could eradicate the human race from the face of earth,
aside from us leaving and some Elysium type fashion,
uh,
what would you,
where would you put in the top sort of three positions as probable causes of
human extinction and would AIB anywhere in that list?
Well,
so probably not dinosaurs.
So I think that like
over that,
um,
I,
you know,
so I'm not afraid of Ai.
I really think the AI debate is a little bit,
uh,
it's,
it's kind of overdramatized and to be honest with you kind of find it weird and
I find that weird for several reasons,
but including this one,
and it's like,
this is hypothesis.
Like,
okay,
we're going to build super intelligent machines and,
and they're going to get exponentially smarter and smarter and like,
so they're going to be basically be much smarter than us and these like super
smart machines are going to make the logical decision that like the best thing
to do is to kill us.
And that just doesn't like,
I feel like there's a couple of steps missing in that like in that chain of
events,
like I don't understand why the obviously smart thing to do would be to kill all
the humans.
Um,
you know,
like the smarter I get the less I want to kill all the humans.
Why wouldn't these like really smart machines not want to be helpful?
Like what is it,
what is it about our guilt as a species that makes us think that like the smart
thing to do would be to kill all the humans.
I think that actually says more about like what we feel guilty about then.
Then what's actually gonna happen.
And if we really think that like a smart decision would be to wipe out humanity,
like it's maybe more useful to instead of like trying to like prevent AI,
maybe it's more useful to think about like,
okay,
what are we so guilty about and let's like,
let's fix that.
Can we,
can we maybe get to a point where we feel proud of our species and say like,
maybe the smart thing to do isn't,
wouldn't be to wipe it out.
I think there's a lot of like important issues that are being,
I dunno,
sublimated into the,
uh,
into the AI will kill all humans discussion that are probably worth pulling
apart in tackling independently.
Um,
so yeah,
I'm just like,
I'm not,
I'm not overly concerned about it.
Um,
I do think that it's worth taking seriously.
I think AI is going to be one of the greatest forces for good in,
you know,
in the universe and the universe is ever seen and it's pretty exciting that we
are actually making progress towards it.
And what,
uh,
if not AI and what would you put at the top of list?
Does anything come to mind is as if the human race were to extinguish itself or
been extinguished in the next say 20 years,
what are the most likely causes in your mind?
Well,
you know,
there's,
there's interesting groups,
right,
that work on this.
There's all those sort of the existential threats groups and you know,
they've got all sorts of,
all sorts of good theories.
I think it's extremely unlikely that the human race gets extinguished in the
next 20 years.
Uh,
I think,
I think there's like,
you can basically isolate this into short term risks,
which are all self inflicted.
Like there's a bunch of self inflicted risks,
like,
you know,
nuclear war,
which is probably still a risk.
I know it's not going to wipe out all humanity,
but it could,
it could,
it could set us back,
uh,
you know,
quite a bit.
Um,
and there's other,
you know,
there's like climate change is a serious issue,
but it's not going to result in wiping out humanity.
It might result in a lot of displacement than a lot of economic costs.
Um,
you know,
there's,
there's global pandemics,
which again,
kind of by their definition,
you know,
a,
a super flew isn't going to wipe out humanity,
but it could be really bad.
It could kill a lot of people.
Uh,
so there's a lot of these like sort of self inflicted risks,
which I think it's important to get a lot better at,
uh,
at uh,
dealing with.
And then there's the real long term stuff,
which obviously at some point we'll wipe out everything on earth.
We were talking about,
you know,
millions of years,
uh,
or even billions of years,
you know,
asteroid impacts,
uh,
you know,
the sun exploding,
Supernova,
that kind of stuff.
Uh,
and the only real solution there is to,
at some point we do need to become a multi planet species.
So,
you know,
no,
no big rush.
We don't all need to like rush towards the exits,
but it is,
it is kind of neat to actually be working on things that will enable us at some
point to,
you know,
spread out a bit.
Steve Wilson,
I think a among other people,
I mean,
Stephen Hawking has said pretty clearly as I understand it,
that,
uh,
for us to survive we have to become multiplanetary,
or extra planetary maybe at the very least.
Yeah,
I think,
I think that's right.
And,
but you know,
it's also an engine.
The question is,
is what,
what does,
what does the US,
right?
So it's plausible that like things that,
that are,
that look like biological human beings actually never live at scale outside of
the planet.
But other things we create,
um,
you know,
other intelligences and consciousness that,
that,
that we create.
Actually my,
my actually won't be able to spread among the stars.
And that's kind of cool to like,
I,
I think it's an elegant idea.
Um,
there's a very cool science fiction short.
It's an animated short,
which is actually also very funny.
Uh,
I think it's,
that's 16 minutes called the world of tomorrow,
which is worth checking out.
It digs into a lot of this.
So as a,
as a side note,
that's a,
that's a fun watch.
You mentioned Netflix.
Do you have any favorite documentaries?
Oh yeah.
Uh,
I have a bunch.
Um,
you know,
I really liked,
uh,
those one that I just saw a couple of weeks ago.
Um,
that was really good.
I think it was called the gatekeepers.
It was like,
it was all the living heads of the Shin Bet,
the Israeli secret service.
Just going to talking very frankly about,
um,
you know,
about life,
about,
about war,
about peace.
Uh,
and it was just kind of kind of startling.
You have these,
you know,
I think it was like eight of them who wound up running,
they were the top kind of military spend,
spy people in Israel and all of them like have had,
have gone,
like all of them were saying things that I think later in life,
uh,
they've,
they've all like moved much more towards reconciliation and peace and dialogue.
And it was just as fascinating,
fascinating to hear.
Uh,
I watch a lot.
Um,
I watch a lot of science documentary,
so it was a big fan of the Neil degrasse Tyson's cosmos.
She boot.
That was great.
I watched all of the Carl Sagan version,
uh,
a while ago.
The thing that I just saw yesterday,
which I didn't actually watch,
I just,
I logged in,
I signed into Netflix yesterday and saw them promoting this,
that she didn't even know they made it.
But I guess there's a new documentary about James Randy called like an honest
liar or something,
which I've now got queued up.
I think I'm probably going to watch that tonight.
I'm a huge James Randy Fam.
Uh,
and I didn't even know they made a movie about him.
So I'm really looking forward to that.
In fact,
the very first,
the very first things that I ever bought on the Internet,
like my first ecommerce transaction,
I have a screenshot on it.
It was on Amazon who was in 1996 and it was a two books by James Randy.
So like the,
the first things I ever bought online where my,
the first two James Randy books I ever read was also the first time I ever used
Amazon.
So it was like,
it was like several important first for me that I've got,
I've got a screenshot in Evernote and I actually met James Randy afterwards and
I had him sign my screenshot in Evernote.
So this sort of a five levels of dorkiness in there,
but I'm pretty proud of it.
Yeah.
This,
this James,
Randy the magician or which James?
Randy.
Yeah.
Yeah,
the amazing Randi James.
Randy the magician slash you know debunker slash skeptic in the same vein is
Penn and teller,
would you say?
Yeah,
he's sort of like,
he's kind of maybe the,
the,
the father of,
of,
of all this other sort of like the modern sort of pro science and skeptical
movement.
Um,
but yeah,
so,
so a little bit,
a little similar dependent Telstra follow James.
Randy doesn't do a whole lot of like magic debunking.
It's more about science teaching and the quackery.
I'm looking at it online here.
It says he has a Ted talk called that it's Randy ran Dai and the title of his
talk is homeopathy,
quackery and fraud.
Yeah,
yeah.
A lot.
So a lot of stuff like that.
And,
uh,
and haven't actually seen the documentary.
So I don't know if it's any good.
I probably is.
Uh,
I just,
I remember seeing,
uh,
yesterday that it was on Netflix and going on.
As soon as I have a spare two hours,
I'm going to watch it.
We should probably be tonight.
Do you have any favorite non documentary movies?
Um,
well,
you know,
the best movie ever made us as the empire strikes back.
I noticed your mug.
So that's that.
Is that your favorite of the Star Wars series?
Yeah.
Well that's objectively the best one really up for debate.
Was it the ton tons that pushed it over?
What?
Oh so much.
It was so much stuff.
Uh,
it's just,
uh,
it's just a really good one that actually I've seen it.
I just,
I watched it again,
uh,
recently,
right,
because they just released like the,
the digital versions of all,
all six movies.
And so I just watched the good three again.
Uh,
yeah,
it's just,
it's just great.
Can we think about it?
All right.
The middle,
the middle movies of trilogies are usually the best ones cause they think like
the first movie,
you know,
the director is still like trying to,
there's,
they're trying a little bit too hard,
you know,
they have to like prove themselves.
And then by the third one they've got to wrap things up.
But the second one is like the pacing is different and sort of the intermediate
thing,
if it has this like sense of continuity but also more to come.
Like just everything about like that the middle part usually is good.
Like I think the two towers was the best Lord of the rings movie and so on.
But,
but,
but return,
but empire strikes back in particular,
it was just like super strong.
So,
uh,
but I also watch,
you know,
I don't,
I don't watch too much TV.
Um,
I uh,
I used to watch top gear.
I'm sorry.
I got you canceled.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
and then,
um,
you know,
I binge watched house of cards and game of Thrones,
although I haven't,
I haven't watched the last season of game of Thrones yet.
Well and just binge watched it,
uh,
this last week.
It's good.
I won't,
I won't give any spoilers.
It's,
it's,
it has a very much has a herky Jerky,
upper and Downer effect,
which I think is very intentional.
Yeah.
I think the series is really good.
Uh,
I've read all the books and I know that last,
the last season supposedly the parts from some of the books a little bit.
So I'm interested to see,
uh,
how that goes.
Do you,
uh,
well actually before I give the the notebook question,
um,
not about the movie with that very beautiful woman.
I'm blanking on her name.
Not that one,
but actual physical notebooks.
Yeah.
Uh,
what do you,
are you attracted to Ryan Gosling?
No,
that's my real question.
Now.
The a tier three me,
he is dreaming.
What book have you gifted most to other people or books?
Um,
probably,
um,
the clock of the long now by a steward brand is maybe the most influential
books,
maybe the most influential book on me.
So it's,
this is,
um,
so I,
you know,
the long now
actually with Denny,
a about the clock and Danny Hillis.
Yeah.
Danny Hillis and Stewart brand,
um,
are kind of the co founders and then there's,
you know,
there's a lot of other people involved.
And so this is the,
this is the organization that's building a 10,000 year clock in like in,
in the middle of the mountain.
And then also preserving like all human languages.
It's,
it's an organization is dedicated to longterm thinking.
Um,
like how do you actually make plans for,
you know,
10,000 years,
which sort of sounds crazy,
but you know,
but it isn't,
and if we can't make plans for 10,000 years and no one else is going to,
um,
and so,
uh,
Stewart brand who is just amazing guy,
I was lucky enough to actually,
I invited him to speak at our last conference and he,
you know,
he agreed.
So it's kind of amazing just to introduce them onstage.
Um,
incredible guy.
Yeah.
He's creator,
a cocreator of the whole earth catalog way back in the day for those people who
remember.
Yep.
Whole Earth Catalog and,
and the well look,
one of the first Internet discussion sites and all sorts stuff.
Uh,
and so his book is the,
the clock of the long now.
And it just talks about,
you know,
the principles and the foundation and it's,
it's a very short read,
but in particular there's one chapter of it,
which is for me it was really like sort of life changing.
Um,
I think it's called like the layers of civilization.
And it basically just talks about,
um,
the six or seven layers of,
of society and kind of how they interact with each other.
And,
uh,
it kind of explains like,
it puts the structure of explaining almost everything that you'd ever wondered
about and like just a few pages.
And so,
uh,
it's really effected me.
I read it,
I read them,
I was pretty young and,
and,
and like I've been kind of going back to it every so often.
So the clock of the long now,
uh,
I've given it lots of times,
definitely couldn't recommend it more highly that.
And I would also highly recommend people check out the long now foundation.
It's,
it's an incredible group of people.
Kevin Kelly's very involved as well.
And it is a way to telescope out and even do thought experiments Solo,
uh,
related to 10,000 year thinking.
For instance,
it's a really fascinating website to check out.
They also have a,
uh,
a bar at a in San Francisco that I contributed to for their Kickstarter campaign
go bottles.
Oh,
you did?
I haven't yet.
I haven't been there yet.
The interval then?
Yeah,
exactly.
The interval as the Fort Mason.
Super Nice.
Yeah,
I've heard it.
It's just gorgeous up now.
When I go to whether it's a coffee shop or a bar,
I almost always have a small mole skin or moleskine there.
I don't know how to say it properly.
Notebook with me.
I have a lot of trouble separating myself from physical notetaking.
Uh,
do you use personally physical notebooks?
I do.
Yeah.
That was weird.
Intonation on the question.
Sorry.
It sounded more like a steel.
Do you use physical notebooks as a statement?
Uh,
but uh,
sorry to interrupt.
I do,
yeah.
What do you use them for and why don't you do everything digitally?
Um,
well it is digital.
So,
um,
our,
our partnership with mole skin is,
is you know,
we can use uh,
well any notebook or most good noble just worked strictly well since we've
optimized our software for it.
And uh,
he just right and then take a picture of an Evernote of the page and it
automatically gets cleaned up and index and scans and kind of put in context
with everything else.
And so just the best of both worlds,
like it lets you be discreet and unintrusive and,
and,
and kind of take notes and uh,
and then immediately have them available digitally for searching and in
reference in sharing.
So it,
it,
it's um,
um,
you know,
we're trying to combine the best of,
we're trying to give people great experiences without being pedantic about,
you know,
what has to be digital with the physical.
We really want,
we really want to blend those two things.
I think I'm,
the best products are made when you take into account the physical world.
When you take into account,
you know,
how things feel like and how heavy they are and where you put your hands.
And it's kind of the same if you're designing iPad software or if you're
actually designing a physical notebook.
You have to think about these things and it's important for us to think about
them and to,
to try and make beautiful experiences that combine those things.
What,
what types of things do you personally put into your physical notebook before
scanning them into Evernote?
So there's a,
there's a little trick.
Um,
I guess I haven't actually told us anyone before.
So here's how this works.
You know how if you're in a meeting and,
um,
you've got your laptop open and you're like taking notes on your laptop,
it's like the like that's a little depth sort of creates a barrier between you
and,
and uh,
and the other people.
And it sometimes feels like a little bit like a little bit distant,
a little bit intimidating.
Definitely.
We actually make stickers that say,
um,
I am like,
I'm not being rude.
I'm taking notes in Evernote that you can stick on the back of your laptop to,
to solve that problem.
Uh,
so or you can use a phone,
but if you use a phone in a meeting with someone,
then it just kind of looks like you're not paying attention to them.
Like all of the dynamics are that you're like texting distracted.
Yeah.
Even if you're taking notes,
but if you use a notebook,
if you like write in a notebook while you're talking to someone,
they feel like,
man,
this person really cares about me.
Like it totally flips the odometer or the other way,
like you are signaling like deep caring and interest.
If you just like scribble in a notebook while talking to someone.
Uh,
and so like even if you're like,
even if you're just like drawing,
you know,
houses and clouds and Unicorns,
but yeah,
big Lebowski style.
Yeah,
exactly.
So it's like the key to like making it look like you are really like paying
attention and connecting with someone and just to like have an open notebook and
occasionally like nod and like write something down.
Um,
so that's,
you know,
that works super well.
So I would say when I'm in meetings,
maybe like a third of the time I'm actually like,
you know,
taking notes.
Um,
and uh,
what I'll do is I'll just write specific words or phrases that a,
I know if I see later will actually like pop the whole meeting into my head.
Yeah.
You're writing down to the keys.
Yeah,
exactly.
Cues and,
and,
and they're not even like necessarily the most important words.
They're just,
yeah,
they're just cues.
Uh,
so like I made that I may write down,
like in this conversation I may have,
I may have like write down like,
you know,
Lebowski,
look,
that was important,
but like that will,
I know that if I saw that later and I saw that that was like on my timeline and
Evernote at the same time that I had this conversation with Tim and you know,
it's linked to you and all of our other stuff,
like that word will just trigger this,
this memory and it'll,
it'll come out.
So I use it for that.
I use it for,
for queuing in a way that doesn't create this barrier between me and the other
person.
And in fact not just doesn't create the barrier.
It actually like,
it actually makes us feel closer and it makes people think that,
uh,
that uh,
I'm really paying attention.
Which you are right.
Which I am.
Yeah,
all the time.
And the process after that,
I'd love to ask about how often do you then scan those into your Evernote?
Do you use your phone to take the photograph?
Do you tear them out and,
and put them through machine?
Uh,
I eat normal people call a scanner.
Yeah.
You always use your phone?
Use my phone.
Yeah.
Uh,
well I use the,
I use the scanner,
I use the Evernote scanner when I have like a stack of documents.
Um,
but um,
if I'm for business cards and for,
and for a handwritten notes,
I always use my phone.
And it's important to do it as close as possible to the time and,
and place of the meeting.
Cause then you get all the,
all the association.
So basically before,
before I get up,
I'll just take a picture and then I know I have it.
I know it's timestamped,
it's,
it's Geo stamped,
it's associated with a calendar entry.
Like basically everything works great if you do it right there,
a business card and handwritten notes.
Uh,
if you wait,
if you wait until you get to the office like you,
you lose all that context.
It's just I never,
I,
I'm embarrassed to say I never even thought about that because you're,
you're not only losing the context,
you are creating false signals because you could be throwing it off and if you
look into your calendar to see why that was associated with a given time,
then you're actually creating a conflict.
Like if I,
if I'm meeting with you,
especially if it's in my calendar and I take a picture of a,
let's say I get your business card and take a picture of that in Evernote,
that will automatically get all your contact info and look you up on Linkedin
and whatever.
And then let's say I take some handwritten notes and I take a picture of that.
The,
the,
the handwritten notes will be automatically titled in Evernote,
you know,
node from meeting with Tim Ferriss and your business card.
We'll have,
we'll have your name and everything associated with it.
So if I did it right there,
I've got all of the stuff.
And so the next time I searched for,
you know,
the next time I,
I,
you know,
write something about you or search for you.
I'm going to get all that stuff coming up and I'm going to see,
I'm going to see my note,
I'm going to see your contact info,
and then I'm going to see all of the,
you know,
any like business articles that have come out about you and any of our publisher
partners.
So it's like,
if you do it,
if you do it right away,
you're just,
you're,
you're really capturing a very strong signal that not only will you use like
right there,
but it'll,
it'll make every subsequent access of this information richer.
When you think,
you mentioned a couple of names earlier,
obviously basis,
uh,
Mikitani,
Benioff Hoffman.
When you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind?
Oh,
I,
uh,
I don't know.
I don't know if my mind works like that.
Uh,
would he mean I,
I you just as successful and I just like I did,
I didn't,
I didn't like pop into a,
into a person.
Uh,
I think I,
like,
I,
I immediately flashed on product,
like the first thing,
the first thing that popped into mind when you say successful was,
was,
was iPhone kind of crazy.
But yeah,
I guess I don't really,
I guess I don't really think of people as successful.
That's a very,
that's a new answer and like this,
so let's explore that.
Why,
why the iPhone?
Well,
maybe it's more like,
why not people?
Because I guess I don't really think of success being as being like the most
interesting characteristic of a person.
I like a lot of success is luck,
right?
I agree.
In fact,
I think that like anyone who's been successful,
even a little bit has also been lucky.
Um,
I,
you know,
luck is not,
and,
and like when I say,
look,
I need look,
I mean like random occurrence.
I don't mean like something like Mr Goal,
you know,
you make your own luck.
Anything.
Like there's a strong element of,
of,
of fortune of random chance to,
to personal success.
And then of course there's also a ton of hard work and really having to,
you know,
maximize it.
Um,
and so tons of people deserve to be successful because they're super smart and
interesting and work hard and you just haven't had the luck.
So to me,
like whether or not a person accessible,
not isn't,
isn't the most interesting thing about that person.
I really care much more about their ideas and,
and you know,
how much,
how interesting or fun they are.
Um,
so I guess I,
I tend,
I tend to think more about like,
about things about products that are successful.
Like,
you know,
like iPhone and that's,
that also has an element of luck but much less.
I think that's much more about really great design and smart planning and great
execution.
And,
and you know,
things that are,
that are more PR,
more predictive and more interesting than applying that measure to people.
Let's make it more general,
and maybe this is,
this will be an equally difficult or misdirected question,
but which historical figure do you most identify with,
if any?
Historical figure.
Uh,
wow.
I Dunno.
Um,
you know,
I don't,
okay.
So
I'm conscious I want to be sensitive to not like sounding like I have,
like I don't want this to come across as false modesty.
Gimme Winnie the Pooh or what or what to wear.
So the thing is like,
I actually don't think about myself that much and,
and I mean serious about this.
I get an in,
in a very specific way.
Like I think,
okay.
So we've already established,
I play a lot of video games.
I don't know.
I actually don't know if you do a,
I'm actually getting,
I'm reinvigorating my game playing as of a few weeks ago.
Okay.
So I stayed a lot of,
I played a lot of dungeons and dragons as,
oh,
I played,
I was all dungeon dragons growing up.
Yeah.
That was,
that was fundamental for me.
Um,
okay,
so there's like basically two types of games and you're like,
I'm like pcs and consoles.
There's um,
kind of first,
first person games,
Third Person Games,
right?
It was like first person shooters and third person shooters,
whatever.
Uh,
and like a first person game is,
uh,
you know,
you're,
you are seeing the game world through the eyes of your character.
So you know,
you're running around and shooting or whatever and then a third person game,
uh,
you know,
and be like,
like grand theft auto or something.
It's like you're kind of the cameras usually like in back of you.
So you're,
you're seeing yourself moving around and interacting in the world.
So in one game you kind of in one genre you sort of see how you look like in the
world and another genre,
you just see the world but you don't really see yourself in it.
Right.
And I think like a lot of people play,
like they go through life either like playing a first player game,
a first person game where third person game.
And I don't think there's like any one of those is right or wrong.
I just think if you look at,
you know,
for example,
if you look at like most politicians like Bill Clinton,
whatever you think of him.
Like he's clearly playing a third person game,
right?
Like he is aware of what he looks like.
Like in any scene,
any sort of optimizing for that and optimizing for,
you know,
how to like do everything correctly cause he's seeing himself and a lot of
people are like that.
And then there's other people who are clearly playing,
you know,
the first person game where they're kind of oblivious about themselves in the
world.
They just like,
they have things they want to accomplish,
they know the way that they want the world to,
to bend,
but they don't really have a perception of them for better or for worse.
Like,
I don't know,
it always felt like just,
you know,
going out with the u s presidents again,
like it always felt like,
like George W.
Bush was probably playing a first person game,
but he's like a little bit less like actual visibility in his own head about
what he looked like interacting with,
with the world.
And again,
that's like obviously not a judgment that all about their political styles or
who you like or don't like or whatever.
Just more of a personality.
And I really think that like,
I'm fundamentally a first,
first person a Gamer.
Like I don't,
I don't think about like,
well,
who do identify with who,
who am I most?
Like,
what do I look like in this scene?
You know,
what do I like?
W W what do I look like from here?
Like,
how do I change my outfit?
Like those were the things that,
that,
that interests me less than what's the world around me.
Uh,
and that,
that probably makes me weak at all sorts of things where I should have better
self awareness.
Uh,
and it probably makes me stronger at other things.
Hmm.
Do you meditate or have meditated?
Practice?
Uh,
you know,
I,
I used to a lot more,
so I went through a phase,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's required if you're going to live in silicon valley,
that thing.
So I went through a zen phase several years ago.
Ben ocular baptism.
Yeah.
Benioff actually got me into it.
A TM or what type of meditation?
No,
you know,
I've never done,
I've never done transcendental stuff.
I'm actually kind of interested in the whole like mantra,
uh,
idea.
I've never done that a sudden just then,
uh,
you know,
mindfulness and Zen and,
um,
now I did it fairly actively for about a year or so.
Um,
and uh,
but I,
you know,
I mastered it.
I won,
I think like I DMC thing is to try really hard to,
you know,
have a goal,
set your mind to it.
And,
and you know,
in Youtube and master,
uh,
can master a Zen Buddhism.
So,
so I became a zen master and,
and uh,
you know,
now I'm on to other things.
Now I'm onto stoicism simulator.
Yeah.
Not,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah,
I'm done.
I've reached,
you know,
level 13 at,
at,
at being a zen monk and the announcement,
the goat simulator.
Why did you stop?
What was the reason for stopping?
Um,
I didn't,
I didn't really stop.
I just sort of,
uh,
I think my,
my,
my commitment to it kind of waned.
So for while was meditating about 20 minutes a day,
um,
and it was good.
It was a very,
very clarifying.
Um,
I then became interested in,
in,
um,
like what could we learn from that and what could we apply to different
products.
Uh,
and then I realized that like as I was meditating,
I was actually just spending more and more of my time,
like thinking about the meditating,
which sort of defeats the whole purpose.
Like I was,
I was treating zen meditation as like a very goal oriented thing,
kind of the opposite of what it's supposed to be.
Right.
Uh,
and then,
um,
so then I started reading more broadly and gone on to other things.
Um,
there's actually a product that a,
I don't know if you've tried,
have you seen the,
the the think no one does that.
T h y n C.
Okay.
Uh,
I see what they're doing there.
Yeah,
it's SORTA super awesome.
And um,
if it works and I've,
you know,
it's so it's so it's basically doing like direct brain stimulation through
ultrasounds.
You wear this device on your head and it would beams,
uh,
vibes into your brain and,
um,
gives you energy or focus or calmness.
And this totally trip,
like every bullshit filter I had when I first saw this like got tripped.
I was like,
yeah,
nonsense.
Um,
but I actually,
like I read into it,
I looked at the science and it seem plausible.
I was like,
oh,
this actually like this,
this isn't setting off like red flags for me in terms of just being
pseudoscience.
Uh,
and so I thought,
okay,
this seems okay.
Um,
and then actually got the,
try it a couple of weeks ago and my personal experience of it was great.
Like I know it was just one person's experience.
It's impossible to really say like what suggestion,
what's placebo,
what's real,
but at a really good experience with it.
So I just,
I just ordered it and it should be getting mine in the next couple of days.
And,
uh,
I'm actually really interested in this and the,
and this idea that like you can actually have significant impact and how you
think through meditation.
Uh,
and,
but you might actually actually be able to have very similar impact in the way
you think.
They're just much more direct application and technology.
Uh,
which would be cool.
So like if I was a robot,
you know,
I would robots meditate.
It'd be something like this.
If you,
I'm looking at it now and,
uh,
the placement,
it looks like there's one,
there's one risk or sensor or stimulator right where I would think it to be,
which is kind of over the right eyebrow.
So the dorsolateral prefrontal contact
cortex,
is there another at the back or is that the only place in point?
Yeah,
so you have the,
so,
so what you're seeing in those pictures is,
um,
the hair's covering up the antenna.
So we should do is you,
you,
you attach to this,
like this flexible antenna would,
you can kind of see like there's like super hot models on the website.
You can like always helps,
right?
Yeah.
You can see the,
the,
so there's two and there's a whole different look like lego Ulises cousin.
Very,
yeah.
Very Elvin.
They're very Elvin.
Yeah.
Uh,
and uh,
so there's,
uh,
there's a contact point.
Uh,
there's,
so there's two different attendance depending on if you're running the calming
one or the,
the energy one.
Uh,
and they go into two different places in the back of your head and yeah,
they kind of aim,
they triangulate that way.
And like I said,
I am so I'm actually super interested in this.
I've talked to the CEO of the company.
I talked to their chief scientist.
I think it like Mike current inclination is that it's legit,
which is kind of amazing.
Yeah.
And uh,
but we'll see.
I'll,
I will do a lot more playing around with it.
Oh,
I should get my into it though.
Let's next time,
next time we're in at the same time zone.
I can bring it over and uh,
you can tell me what you think.
Yeah,
that'd be great.
I'd love to play with it.
There is,
um,
it looks like transcranial direct current stimulation,
which uh,
there is,
um,
friend of mine,
if you don't know him,
I should introduce you guys named Adam Gazzaley who runs the galley neuroscience
lab at Ucla and they do a lot of work with this type of technology.
So I've,
I've actually been a subject and an experimenter in some of their research
studies for tdcs.
So yeah,
I think there's,
I think there's a lot of promise.
You just have to make sure you don't fry your brain into scrambled eggs
accidentally.
Yeah.
You know,
details.
Well,
I think that,
I think the tdcs could be this type of brain stimulation could be very
interesting also,
not just for the direct impact on say,
performance or subjective state of mind or emotion,
but also for showing people what might be possible through meditative practice
in the same way that there's a neuroscience phd and a friend of mine named Sam
Harris,
who's also on this podcast who no longer uses psychedelics.
But his,
his early formative psychedelic experiences showed him what could be possible
with dedicated meditative practice.
And that's,
that's the tool that he now uses.
So the interplay of all of those,
uh,
all of these different tools for expanding or honing consciousness is very
interesting to me.
Uh,
which do you use a think mostly for calming or stimulating or both?
So I,
I've only actually used that one,
so I don't,
I don't own one yet.
I'm,
you know,
I've,
I've put in,
my order should be showing up soon.
So I've had one direct experience with it,
um,
which was in London a few weeks ago and I did the calming Vibe,
uh,
and it was great.
Now basically,
I mean,
like the,
the,
the woman that was putting it on me says,
um,
uh,
you know,
you should,
as you're using it,
she said you should look for signs to see whether or not it's working.
And it's like,
okay,
like what?
She goes like,
wow,
for example,
um,
you know,
can you think of some things that like right now,
if you think of them,
they just kind of cause you to get like,
anxious or stressed out or angry.
And I'm like,
Yep.
Done as a CEO,
pretty easy.
She's like,
okay,
good.
Uh,
so I can five minutes,
like think of those things again and see how you make me feel,
see how they make you feel.
And it's okay.
So I put this thing on and controlling with my iPhone and I'm feeling relatively
calm and then like five minutes go by and I start thinking about these things.
It just causes me this like fundamental stress and anxiety five minutes earlier.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'm cool with that.
That's okay.
I can,
I can live with that.
That,
that,
that seems normal I think.
I think like that's not a problem.
And yeah,
I'm comfortable with that.
And it was just like,
it was really impressive to me.
And,
and I know,
I know that could be like 100% suggestion or placebo.
Um,
but like what I've read about it combined with,
with talking to the people that I know combined with direct experience,
like it's definitely making me relatively sanguine about the possibilities.
Ooh,
goodness.
Where it sanguine,
I always get out juried by my guests on this podcast.
It's an issue I need to really need to get some flashcards.
Uh,
so speaking of purchases in the last,
say six to 12 months,
it could be whatever comes to mind,
what $100 or less purchase has most positively impacted your life?
Hmm.
$100 or less.
Yes.
It's a start.
It's a starting point.
If any purchase comes to mind that isn't completely out of reach of most people,
then that's fine.
Um,
hmm.
No,
let me,
when you think about it,
um,
we've definitely,
like for some reason my mind like goes to food.
That's fine.
Um,
so I have a,
um,
like,
yeah,
I dunno.
I don't know if that's weird.
Maybe it's just cause I'm hungry.
It's like getting close to lunchtime.
So like I'm thinking about,
uh,
I'm thinking about this amazing,
um,
a hamburger that I hadn't Tokyo,
uh,
which was,
but anyway,
I can't really say those,
those,
those life changing
or just,
I mean it positive.
It does.
It does sound like it positively impacted your life.
What was,
was there anything special about the hamburger that comes to mind?
So there's this place
gins up that uh,
uh,
makes a smoked stuff,
which is kind of unusual in Japan.
They don't really have smoked food culture,
but this place just makes like smoked everything,
like smoked hamburgers and smoked olive oil and smoke soy sauce and smoke rice
and eggs and just amazingly good.
And they make the world's best hamburger.
Like my favorite hamburger in the world is in this place.
And they also make amazing eggs.
They've got these like beautiful,
you know,
orange in color,
like totally fresh,
you know,
eggs that they can put on stuff.
And last night I was there,
I'm actually about a year ago I decided I would try to get them to put a fried
egg on my hamburger.
And this took like 45 minutes of like intense negotiation.
And they were like,
they were very skeptical about putting this egg and the hamburger,
like it had never been done before.
And I was like,
come on.
And then they were like really kind of nervous about disappointing me,
like show how to do it.
So it was like about a minute,
so Japanese,
a lot about 45 minutes of like convincing them and then like exactly how to fry
the egg and put on top.
And so they finally did it and I had it and was like,
it was amazing cause I was like,
the only way that you can improve like the best of worlds,
best smoked hamburgers to put like a perfectly fried,
runny egg on it.
Uh,
it was great,
but they were very,
like you could tell they were deeply uncomfortable with this whole experience.
And then I went back there,
um,
a year later and it's on the menu.
Oh Wow.
So I was like,
my contribution to,
to Japanese cuisine is it called the Libon now.
They didn't name it after me.
I was kind of
Kinda Kinda bummed the,
uh,
I don't think they know my name.
So what is,
what is the,
the man with no name that's the,
that's probably how you're listed on the reservation.
D they don't want to,
they don't want to summon you to,
to to put them into more uncomfortable culinary situations.
What,
what was the name of the place do you recall?
Uh,
it's called Ginza ng Ginza in g and G.
A I cool.
And a good Ginza in GE.
Very cool.
Uh,
yeah,
that was probably the best,
the best sub hundred dollars purchase in the past past year or so.
Wow.
Well next time I'm there I'll have to check out [inaudible].
It's a very,
uh,
it's a very rundown sheet part of Tokyo for those people wondering,
Hey,
it was significantly less than a hundred dollars.
Even in Ginza you can get here.
Literally means like the golden throne or the golden seat button to,
it's a fancy neighborhood.
The easy to get to.
And I think that is also,
correct me if I'm wrong,
I might be getting this totally wrong,
but the Jiro dreams of Sushi,
it's same thing.
Yeah.
It's in the same subway station building.
Right?
It's all the same building.
Yeah,
that's right.
It's like the same.
Yeah,
it's right there.
Yeah.
If anyone listening hasn't seen Jiro dreams of Sushi,
very well worth watching.
Uh,
what are your now just to,
it's actually a good segway.
So that movie is chock full of routines,
right?
It's very methodical in that restaurant.
What are your morning rituals?
What does,
what does the first 60 minutes of your day look like on a day that that is one
that you're free to design sort of your ideal for 60 minutes?
Oh,
well,
I don't know if I've had an ideal day in a,
in a long time.
I mean,
my actual day is I wake up and I grabbed my phone and uh,
you know,
I see like I see if there's any emergencies and usually,
usually there aren't any.
And then I,
what time do you wake up?
Um,
you know,
I don't really have a fixed schedule,
so I,
um,
I don't have kids,
so it's,
it's fairly easy to,
you know,
not,
not wake up at any particular time.
So I usually wake up like a couple of hours before my first meeting,
uh,
maybe,
maybe two to three hours before my first meeting just so I have time to like
catch up on a little bit of work before,
you know,
before it hit to the office.
So if my,
if my first meeting,
you know,
my first meeting is up nine,
I'll wake up at six,
six 30.
Uh,
but usually I try to schedule meetings.
I tried to,
I'm not like a morning person,
so I try to schedule my meetings a little bit later so sometimes they'll sleep
late or something.
And then,
uh,
I'll kind of walk around the house for four 45 minutes,
you know,
drinking coffee and usually,
with my phone or my hand checking on various things and,
and it gets started slowly.
What I would like is,
um,
I'd like maybe like I would like to have my digest of the day be more automatic.
Like I would like to hear about like what's going to happen,
what do I need to know about?
Um,
I'd kind of like,
I've experimented with setting up various ways where I can maybe like have an
RSS fee that I could have read to me or like something like that.
And there's,
there's,
you know,
I've had mixed success with that,
but it'd be cool to like,
it'd be cool to work on something like that.
And that's the digest,
like your primer for the day to come.
Yeah.
Though that'll be,
that'll be kind of cool cause I find like at that time in the morning,
like I don't really want to be making decisions,
but it's a good time and I definitely want to be like talking to people.
Uh,
but it's a good time too.
It's like my brain is still spongy at that point is a good time to like soak in
like,
okay,
here's what's going to happen.
Here's what I'm going to need to start thinking about.
Uh,
that's,
that's productive.
I hate,
like,
I hate early morning meetings.
Those are those done not to go well for me.
Yeah,
I know the feeling.
And um,
do you,
do you have any particular evening rituals or ways that you prep for the next
day that help you get off to a good start?
I don't anymore.
I used to,
so I used to back.
So when I was meditating for about a year or so,
I would try to meditate for 20 minutes every day in the evening.
And then I just started like being too tired,
so I would just fall asleep in the middle of it.
Uh,
which,
you know,
isn't,
isn't super good.
Um,
and so this one,
I don't really have any particular thing.
I,
I've,
I've gone back and forth.
Like I,
I tend to try out a lot of the sort of faddish things.
I've tried out the,
okay,
don't look at a screen for the last few hours,
you know,
just like read a physical book or,
don't watch TV or look at a laptops.
I've done that,
but that didn't really seem to make much of a difference.
Plus they don't,
I don't really have trouble sleeping,
like I sleep pretty well.
Um,
so I don't like,
I don't,
I think I'm just lucky,
I'm just sort of wired up where,
you know,
when I go to bed I fall asleep regardless of kind of what else I was doing.
I'm looking forward to getting the machine and maybe using that to calm down a
little bit before sleep.
Um,
but at this point I don't have any,
any kind of fixed,
uh,
routine.
Got It.
For people interested in exploring the paths that you've explored for thinking
about meaning,
why we're here,
purpose,
et cetera.
Uh,
we touched on stoicism briefly,
but if you had to recommend or yeah,
if you had to recommend one to three books that you have found very thought
provoking,
what would you recommend?
So I would say,
so the clock of the long now.
Definitely.
Yeah.
That's just like as,
as sort of a,
the set the stage for like how to think about things.
It's,
it's great.
Um,
excuse me.
I think,
um,
a book that really had a profound influence on me pretty early on was,
uh,
the selfish gene,
by,
by Dawkins.
Yup.
And I think that was just reissued in like some like 25th anniversary edition or
something that I just saw,
which is sort of sad that it was 25 years ago that I read it.
Um,
so that's definitely worth reading for just all sorts of like brain expanding
ideas.
And then,
um,
you know,
for,
in terms of philosophy,
uh,
there's a really a good introduction to,
to Stoicism,
um,
that I read about a year ago when I first started looking into this.
I forget the author,
but the title is a,
a good life.
Yeah.
That is a good synopsis.
Uh,
and yeah,
it was pretty good.
Like it wasn't like the writing itself,
I think it wasn't particularly,
you know,
shining,
but like it,
it captured the ideas and presented them in a fairly modern way,
you know,
pretty elegantly.
So that was a good jumping off point to a bunch of other stops.
I would like if I,
if I had to give three,
I would say,
you know,
let's say those,
those three.
Um,
but,
you know,
really I think the important thing for me is to really try to have a coherent
philosophy of life.
And I think a lot of people,
like a lot of people don't,
they,
they sort of think it's like pretentious to pretend that you can have a coherent
philosophy.
Why is that important to you?
What does it allow you to do or help you do?
Um,
just kind of frames everything and gives,
it,
gives a reason for things.
Like,
I think this is well understood,
right?
Motivation.
So if you're trying to just,
you know,
philosophy aside,
right?
You're just trying to communicate with people,
you know,
you're,
you're a CEO and you're trying to get people to do what you want.
It's like proven that people,
it's much more effective to give people a reason.
Uh,
and actually it turns out that like,
the reason it doesn't really matter that much,
what matters is that there is a reason.
Yeah.
So if you say like,
Hey,
you should do this.
And it's like far more effective to say,
hey,
you should do this because you know,
x,
y,
and Z.
And it turns out that even if like the people don't,
don't even understand the x,
Y and Z,
as long as they,
they've like heard a,
it just like fits much more neatly into the brain.
Yeah.
Then then if they have it.
So like having a reason just make smart people far more productive and
effective.
Um,
and that's just very true of me.
Like I want to have a reason for,
for things.
I don't want to feel like I am doing things.
Um,
you know,
so shrouded by this existential mystery.
I want to thank that.
Like I want to have a structure to think about why I am making certain decisions
and,
and uh,
having like having a career in philosophy makes up,
you know,
it makes that possible
philosophy is,
would it be comparable in some ways to the 10 commandments where it's like,
if you're like,
should I covet thy neighbor's wife or not?
I'm not sure.
It's like,
well,
no,
it says do not covet thy neighbor's wife.
Therefore,
decision made and like that's the reason.
Is it sort of a,
a,
do you view it as a set of guidelines and a framework for kind of decision
making in life for simplifying things?
Or is it more than that?
So the 10 commandments wouldn't serve this purpose for me just because they
don't actually answer the why.
Like they're actually like the way the 10 commandments are afraid to have the
because,
right.
Or that's exactly it.
Sort of like exactly the cognitively wrong way to do it though.
Those are just commandments.
They're not,
they're not explanations.
Now there's a lot of religious theory and thought about about the why.
So if you're a religious person that you want to base your life around the 10
commandments,
it's probably possible.
And it's probably possible to actually read quite a bit of,
of,
you know,
other commentary that actually give,
compelling reasons.
Um,
you know,
if that's,
if,
if that's the,
the most appealing thing.
Uh,
so I,
I kind of prefer to have the why rather than just the,
you know,
the what,
um,
and uh,
I don't,
you know,
I don't have the exact answers obviously,
but I have,
you know,
I think,
I think I'm getting,
I'm getting like a better,
a better feeling that things aren't random.
There is a purpose and I'm like,
I can,
I can work towards like making the world better in this specific way in which I
wanted to be made better and,
and that feels great.
And that's,
that's,
that's much more motivating than kind of getting up and following orders or
getting up and not understanding why.
So is your intention then to communicate this to employees or partners or is
this really something for your own internal use?
Oh,
well,
I'm definitely,
I'm pretty,
you know,
apprehensive about talking about anything that sounds like this to,
to employees.
Like the last thing I want as you know it to be imposing any kind of
philosophical worldview,
uh,
on people.
So,
you know,
if we were having a off the record conversations over a few drinks,
I'm always happy to talk about it.
But yeah,
this is not a,
my,
my mission in life is not to to convince anybody of anything.
I just want to have a structure for myself,
be like fill over the branch Davidians.
It's not the book that you mentioned,
I looked up,
uh,
the,
the stoic overview is by William Irvine and it's a guide to the good life.
And then the subtitle is the ancient art
of stoic joy.
Yeah.
Which is a good overview.
It is.
Then it's not,
it's not what I thought it was like,
you know,
I remember studying stoicism in high school or whatever and uh,
I think I had all the wrong ideas about,
about,
about what it is.
So it was actually,
it was a very interesting read.
Yeah.
It's,
it's helpful because it disabuse people of the notion that stoics are,
I remember the description I heard at one point was,
um,
being a stoic is like being a cow standing in the rain.
And it's like,
no,
it's not quite that.
Not Quite,
that's that serious or devoid of positive emotion.
Uh,
if you could have a,
I know we have just a few minutes left.
If you could have a billboard anywhere,
what would it say and where would you put it?
Well,
you know,
this is like,
what are we talking about this as like one of my main goals in life?
Oh No,
I don't think we have,
oh yeah.
Like one of the main things that I want to,
that I want to do is I want to be on a billboard advertising whiskey in,
in Japan.
I want to be in a giant Japanese whiskey billboard,
like totally Bill Murray style.
And,
but this is like a serious goal of mine.
I've been like,
sort of like working towards it for a while.
I've,
like,
I've talked to the right distillers and like,
yeah,
I think it was a chance that'll happen.
We should make,
we should make this happen.
Yeah.
Let me know,
like giant billboard of me like holding a glass of Whiskey,
um,
in,
you know,
in Tokyo,
it's kind of an uncle.
I even,
I've even figured out what it's going to say.
What is it going to say?
There's going to be just,
you know,
so just imagine,
it's me with a big glass of whisky and a,
the caption will say,
um,
Evernote helps you remember,
Suntory helps you forget
that is fantastic.
It's Kinda,
it kinda feels like it needs to happen,
right?
Yeah.
Or You could have,
you know,
I just thought of another one you could say Evernote is forever.
Suntory is for tonight and also good.
Yeah.
I'm a whole series of things you could,
that's amazing.
It makes me,
it makes me think of the,
the,
the commercial shoot from lost in translation when he's,
when the director talks for like three minutes and the guy's like more energy or
whatever.
And he's like,
I think he said more than that.
Uh,
one of my favorite movies.
so good.
What's,
um,
one of my favorite parts is actually an improvised part in that movie when he's
waiting in the hospital waiting room.
And those ladies are all cracking up.
Right.
I'm just such a good movie.
Uh,
advice to your 30 year old self.
If you had to give advice to your 30 year old self,
what would it be?
Uh,
if I had a time machine or something.
Yeah,
yeah.
If you had a time machine and could deliver,
deliver advice to your 30 year old self that if I had a time machine I can go
back.
So I'm 43 now so I can go back 13 years and talked to him a third years off.
I would be like a,
that'd be like,
dude,
don't worry about anything because in 13 years you're gonna have a time machine.
Nothing,
nothing else really matters.
That is a good answer.
Uh,
I think I would say it.
So when I was 30,
I was working on stuff that I didn't,
I was working on my second company and I didn't,
like,
I wasn't in love with it.
I wasn't,
I wasn't building it for my,
for myself.
It was building it for somebody else.
And,
um,
I think what I would have said is like,
stop taking people seriously when they say you have to like worry about what,
what the market wants.
And just like build what you want.
And I kind of wish I had,
I had gotten started with that and my twenties rather than in my mid thirties
so any other parting advice or do you have an ask or suggestion for everybody
listening?
Well,
um,
you know,
everyone should,
everyone listening should obviously read every word
word of a,
of all of your books,
you know,
insight forward and back inside and out.
Especially especially the chapter in the four hour body.
That's about me.
That's right.
The Excel spreadsheet.
Cause it just makes sense because obviously you can't write a book about
attaining the perfect body without having a chapter about me.
And in the updated edition that will be published in a year or two.
We'll talk about your,
your pull up quest.
My pool quest is good.
And I know there's actually a bunch of more to say.
You know,
I've,
I've lost,
I think since the last time we've seen each other.
I've lost about 50 pounds.
Wow.
Congratulations.
That's a very,
that's a sturdy,
robust toddler right there.
Yeah.
I actually,
I just saw one time like Getty images.
Sure.
Whatever.
I need to search for myself on Getty images and there's like,
there was like eight years of like,
you know,
pictures of me and it's like I'm aging in reverse.
That's great actually.
Like,
it's kind of cool,
like eight years ago,
I'm like,
you know,
250 pounds and I'm wearing a suit and tie and I have a beard.
And then just like slowly over eight years,
like first the suit disappears,
you know,
then the color and I'm like,
the tie the beer,
you know,
50 pounds.
It's like,
I'm definitely in this localized minimize the kind of looks like a majoring
universe,
which is kind of cool.
So I'm just going to assume that that's going to continue forever.
I don't,
I don't see why it wouldn't.
Um,
but we'll see how it goes.
Benjamin Button.
But in real life,
exactly.
The curious case of Phil Libin,
but that could be your mom,
your memoir,
uh,
where can people find you online?
Where can people connect with you on the social media?
Yeah.
And where can they of course find out more about Evernote and give it a spin?
Well,
uh,
so Evernote is just that evernote.com or your favorite APP store.
And I am a on Twitter,
I'm p libbing and uh,
also happy to chat with anyone via email or anything else.
I'm Phil that Evernote.
Um,
my policy is a,
I've been super lucky in um,
uh,
just being
able to get great advice from people when,
when I ask.
So if anyone actually wants to talk to me and my policy is I have to eat lunch
anyway,
so anytime anyone wants to come over for lunch,
I'm happy to do that.
So if anyone's in the area,
send me a note and a come on by for lunch.
If you're actually,
if you actually want to talk,
your lunches may just become very exciting from this point forward.
We'll fill,
you're always very generous with your time.
You're always fun to hang out with.
And uh,
there are many more topics we could discuss.
So perhaps sometime we'll do around two people can let us know what other
questions they might have for us to explore.
And I'm looking at these questions in Evernote.
I'm thankful for the product.
I've used it for all of my books since we met.
I've used it for planning the TV show,
I've used it for all of the planning around the podcast is a,
it is my go to sort of central repository for everything.
So I want to thank you for that.
And of course and uh,
I think we should have some whiskey soon and plan that billboard.
Let's do it.
All right man.
Thanks so much.
I will talk to you soon.
Take care of him.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
My answer is inevitably athletic Greens.
It is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my gosh,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash.
Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty,
but more important.
It will help you not screw up when you're doing your nutritional plannings.
For me,
just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One,
Wall Street Journal,
and the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world,
we'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward.
And many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
and until next time,
thank you for listening.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.